this course will help you improve your
skills with html and css
popular instructor john smilga will
teach you how to create a multi-page
recipe website using just html and css
hey what's up it's john from coding
addict and welcome to another html and
css project
and this video will build a multi-page
food recipe site
if you want to see the entire project in
action
just navigate to the url html css
simplyrecipes.netfly.app
again the url is html css
simplyrecipes.netfly.app
and effectively we've got a recipe site
with bunch of pages so we've got a home
page
an about page the tags page and then
once we click on a tag
we navigate to a tag template page we
also got recipes page as well as the
contact page
and also if we click on a single recipe
we'll have a single recipe page before
we start setting up the project let me
just mention that since it's a html and
css project there's going to be very
minimal functionality and some copy and
pasting since in plain html there are no
templates or components so for example
if you want to display navbar and all
pages yes you will have to copy and
paste since there's no way around it in
order to follow along with the project
you'll need a star and probably the
fastest way to get it is by navigating
to john's milk dot com again the url is
johnsmiller.com
and then look for the project page
and then filter by youtube so check for
youtube project and in here if you click
on this button of course you'll navigate
to the project the one that i just
showed you but you're looking for the
stars so just click on the star or the
source code both of them lead to the
same repo
and once you get here just look for
download zip option
and once you download the zip of course
you want to crack it open here and then
i'll just drag and drop and place it
on desktop i'll use my favorite text
editor
visual studio code
and i always prefer
working side by side with a browser
window so open up the browser
i'll set them side by side and then
we'll go over what you can find in the
project
and essentially we've got two folders
we've got a final one and the star one
and of course in the final is where
you'll find the entire source code just
in case you ever need a reference
and the starter is where we'll be doing
all of our work
in the starter you'll find the general
structure for the project
so i already prepared some stuff for you
like we have assets so this is where
you'll find all the images some css
files that i'm going to talk about a
little bit later
some empty html pages so these are all
the pages that eventually will create
as well as one lonely javascript file
and if you take a look at the index.html
you'll find here the general setup
where essentially we've got some link
tags so one is going to be for
favicon then the next one will be for
normalized css we also have one for
fantasm icons and one for
main css and if you take a look at the
main css you'll find some global styles
that i use in all of my projects
if you're confused about some of this
stuff for example why i use normalize
and what is the benefit of global styles
please watch my default star video where
i cover all of that in great detail
and you can find the video link in the
description lastly while working on html
css project i prefer extension called
preview on the web which spins up the
local web server and as a result once i
save the file i can see the changes
instantly so let me show you so these
are my extensions
and the one that i prefer using is this
one
the preview on a web server and of
course you just need to install it and
then if you want to see it in a browser
you can either right click it and i'll
show you that in a second
or you can use this shortcut so once you
install the extension
just navigate to index.html in the
starter so of course this is where we'll
do the work now if you want to check out
the final of course navigate there and
then like i said we can right click over
here and then choose this option
or you can just go
for the shortcut and i believe it was
ctrl shift
and l
and once you spin it up you should see a
home page in a browser and like i said
the reason why i prefer using this
extension is because every time you make
some kind of changes you'll right away
see that in the browser so if i go here
with hello people and once i save the
file check it out now of course i have
the element
displayed in the browser and then lastly
once in a while i want to showcase what
we've got on a big screen as well so
therefore i'll navigate here and then
i'll just copy and paste this url so
essentially i'll have two browsers one
is going to be the small one where
you'll see the result right away and
once in a while i'll hop back to the big
browser just to showcase how something
looks on a big screen as well
all right and we're going to kick things
off with a navbar which has two layouts
we have a small screen layout and a big
screen layout and on a small screen we
can also toggle the links
so let me make this smaller and notice
this is going to be
a small screen layout where of course we
can toggle the link now i also probably
forgot to tell you that
when i'm recording
i actually zoom in
so that's why everything looks so big
technically if i go back to 100
now of course you'll see that everything
is smaller so don't be surprised if at
some point your application looks a
little bit different than mine so let me
make this big and then i'm gonna
navigate back
to the index.html again i'm using my web
server
located in the star
in the index.html and of course as
always we just need to start by adding
the html
and we're going to do that in the
following way where of course i'll
remove all the code all the dummy code
and i'll close the sidebar just so we
have more real estate say nav and then
let's add end of nav that's just my
preference
and then let's go with nav element also
right away add a class of navbar and
inside of the navbar i want to go with
nav center div
and then instead of this div we're going
to have two more one is going to be four
nav links and one is going to be for nav
adder so first let's set up the header
and again i'm going to use some comments
here so let's say
nav header
so in here we'll place a logo with
toggle button and then also we'll have
one for nav links of course this is
where all the links are going to be
now as far as nav center why i prefer
sticking it in the nav bar because that
way on a big screen
i can always make sure
that the nav content is spanning only
certain width and of course i'll show
you once we start styling the big screen
because notice navbar actually is going
to be spanning all across but then as
far as the content the nav center one
that will always be certain width
and that's why i have that nav center
inside of the navbar now when it comes
to header we want to place two things
over here we have a link back to the
home page so basically i'm wrapping my
image in the link so we can always
navigate back home
and just to showcase how is that going
to look like if i go to about page
that's the look but if i want to
navigate back i can either click on home
or i can simply click on a logo and i'll
be back home and then the second thing
is the toggle button which of course is
going to have that font awesome icon so
let's start with a link as far as the
href we're going to go with index.html
and of course this is going to make
sense
once we add this nav bar to different
pages because of course we're already
located in the index.html then we'll add
a class of nav logo and then inside of
this link let's go with img and then
all the images are going to be in the
assets and then more specifically we
have recipes one so these ones we'll use
a little bit later but then for the
about for the main one as well as logo
well they're just going to be located
right in the assets folder
so let's set up the path
i'm going to go with forward slash
looking for assets and as far as logo
well we're just looking for
logo svg and then let's add a
alternative text and we'll say here
simply recipes let's say that one we
should see the logo on screen and of
course we do and after that let's set up
that button
and this button is going to have two
classes it's going to have a class of
btn so this is coming from the global
styles as well as the nav btn because
we'll add a little bit more styling and
also you know what let's add a type and
let's say that is going to be equal to
the button
then instead of the button like i said
we're going to go with font awesome icon
so we're looking for i element and of
course
i can access these classes because i
have the link to the file assume notice
over here so that's the cdn link for
fantasm and then as far as the classes
we're looking for fas
and then fa and align
and justify so once i have my element of
course i should see my icon and since i
do we can move on to the next thing so
once we set up the header over here then
we want to add a comment of links and as
the name already suggests
in the nav links will have a bunch of
link elements
but one of them the last one contact one
is going to be wrapped in a div because
it will have a little bit different
styling notice on a big screen has
different styling and of course also on
a small screen and because of that of
course we'll wrap it in a div
so let's create four links and we need
to make sure that the values for the
href actually match our pages otherwise
it's not going to make sense and i'll
start with index.html and as far as the
text i'm going to go with home but we
also want to add a class of nav link and
then i'm going to have one for about one
for tags and one for recipes again make
sure
that the href value actually matches the
pages that we have over here so let me
toggle the sidebar and then i'll copy
and paste four times
and then as far as the values i'm going
to go with about html
then i'm looking for tags.html
and the last one will be recipes html so
recipes html all of them have the class
of nav link so that stays the same and
now of course we just want to change
these values around as far as the text
ones so let me select them
i'm going to look for home i'll remove
all of them
and then we'll go with about
then we're looking for tags
and of course the last one will be
recipes
and like i already previously mentioned
when it comes to contact yes it's going
to be a link yes it's going to navigate
to the contact page but we'll wrap it in
a div with two classes with the navlan
class as well as the contact link class
so let's say here nav link
another class contact link
so contact hyphen
and link and then inside of this div
let's go with another href element and
we'll say contact
html and then let's just add a class of
button and of course as far as the text
we'll go with contact
and that should do it for the html
and as far as the logo i created infigma
which is arguably the most popular web
design software out there it's very it's
very easy to get started and you can
easily find bunch of great tutorials on
how to get up and running with figma on
youtube as well as udemy and once the
bones are in place of course now we can
just start styling the navbar nice and
once we have the html in place
now of course let's start styling and
first we'll worry about the small screen
layout so first i want to set this one
up
and then we'll worry about the toggle
effect
and only then
we'll set up the big screen layout
and we're going to do that by navigating
to main css again it is located in the
css folder
and more specifically main css and then
we have the navbar comment so these are
all the global styles and then right
after the navbar comment we'll start
styling and let's just start with nav
center and eventually there's also going
to be some styles for the navbar but for
time being they'll probably not going to
make sense so i'll just add selector for
the entire navbar and first we'll start
with now center and then you'll see what
styles we want to add to the nav bar as
well so let's start over here and i just
want to go with some kind of width um
since i want to set up this with fluid
meaning i want to set it based on a
screen size i'm going to go with width
and then 90 view widths so those are the
units and essentially that just means
90 percent of the screen width
regardless whether that's really small
or really big and then as far as the max
width
we're going to go over here and then
remember i mentioned that i'm going to
be using the css variable for that and
in my global styles i have max width set
to 1120 pixels so that's the width i'm
going to use so let me go back and in
here i'm just going to say half an
hyphen and then max width and what this
means is that our content in navbar
is never going to be bigger than 11 20.
that's why we have the nav center and
that's why we added of course that max
width
now you'll notice right now that of
course the now center is all the way in
the left hand side why well because we
have the width but we haven't set up the
margin or we haven't styled the parent
container so we have two choices either
you go here with margin 0 and auto so
that will also always place it in the
center
or we can work with a parent container
and in this case we'll just say display
flex
and then justify content we'll set it in
the center and lastly we'll go with
align items and we'll set it equal to
center but i can tell you right away
that we won't be able to see that why
well because navbar doesn't have any
height
so once we add the height and that is
going to be on a big screen then we'll
actually see this property in action
and if you're ever in doubt i highly
suggest just adding the background so in
this case let's say you're confused
what's happening with map center simply
go with background and then set it equal
to red again this is just going to be
temporary and then you can do the same
thing with the navbar and change it
around and set it equal to blue and what
you'll notice
once you go to the big screen so this is
going to be that nav center it's never
going to be bigger than that
1120 and this is the remaining of the
number again if you're ever in doubt two
options either you can set up the border
that's also something that people use
or you can just add the background
colors and that way you can clearly see
okay so this is my nav center and this
is the remaining of the nav and now of
course since i have justify content
sender you can clearly see that the nav
center is sitting in the center
of the nav bar so now let me comment
these ones out
because they're useful but they're also
a little bit annoying because of course
i don't want to look at the red color
all the time
and up next i want to go with header so
now of course we're styling
where we have the logo as well as the
button and this is going to be the case
where i'll set up the height and i'm
going to go with 6 rems and what's
really interesting that once we get to
the big screen we'll change this height
around and effectively we'll add the
height to the entire navbar but for now
since we're just styling the small
screen we'll go with height 6 rdm for
the header and then again we want to go
with display flex
and we'll go with justify content and
we'll set it space between and
essentially in here we're just pushing
these items as far as possible away from
each other so notice now buttons are all
the way and right-hand side
and the logo is all the way on the
left-hand side and then i also want to
set them up in the center vertically and
of course in order to do that we just go
with align items and center of course
you can use the grid for that
but it's just always my preference to
stick with flex if you have these
straight up horizontal and vertical
layouts of course once it starts to get
more complex then grid is always a
better choice and after that i want to
make my logo a little bit smaller
so go with nav header
and then i'll target the image
and essentially i just want to go with
200 pixels so now you'll see that of
course our logo is a little bit smaller
then we want to go with nav button as
you can see we already have a bunch of
styles applied because we're using that
global button class but i just want to
add a little bit different padding so in
here let's go with nav btn and then i'm
looking for padding
0.15
and of course i'm going to go with rems
and then the same thing is going to be
over here where we'll go with
0.75 rms essentially in here just make
this padding a little bit smaller and
this one a little bit bigger of course
that is a choice if you don't want that
you don't have to apply these styles and
then let's go for font awesome and that
one is of course the i element so i'll
go with nav btn and then i'll set the
font size equal to 1.25
so 1.25 rms and once we have the map
button in place
then i just want to go for the links so
of course now i'm talking about the
entire list and as far as the nav links
i'll set it equal to a display flex
again so display flex and we're going to
go with flex direction equal to a column
so now of course instead of being in one
line they're stacked one on top of each
other
and then there's going to be more styles
so i'll add here to do but we'll worry
about them once we start actually
toggling the links and then we'll right
away go for that one individual link
another one has a class of nav link and
here let's go with display block
so we'll change from the inline one to
your display block then we want to go
for text align and we'll set it equal to
center so now of course
all the text is in the center then let's
also add text transform
and we're just going to go with
capitalize
and after that let's add a different
color and in this case i'm going to go
for the gray one but i'm going to go for
900. so now of course all the links have
the same color as our text and then
let's go for letter spacing and that
will be equal to our css variable
then we want to add a padding
but we'll only add padding top bottom so
padding one rem and then left and right
zero and also i want to add a border on
the top so let's go border top one
pixels solid and then we're shooting for
our css variable so again i'm going to
go for gray and 500 so that's going to
be my border and then i also want to add
transition because as we'll be hovering
i'll change the color of my link so i'm
going to go over here with transition
that is equal to my css variable of
course in the global styles and then
let's just go with nav link and then
hover so as we're hovering we want to
change the color and we'll set it equal
to the primary one and then lastly as
far as this contact length i just want
to change the padding again just like we
did over here with the nav button and in
order to do that we just go here with
contact and then link and i'm targeting
the actual link element here so i have
the class and then i'm targeting the
link and in here let's go with padding
and again i'm going to go with
0.15 rems and then 1 rem's left and
right and once we're done styling the
contact link we're almost almost done
but before i let you go there's
something that i want to point out and
that is simply the fact that if you take
a look at the logo
and button
you probably noticed that even though i
set up for a parent
for the header to be align items in the
center the logo and the button are not
vertically in the same line now first of
all let's take a look at why is that
happening well remember in the index
html
we have of course a link
and then link wraps the image
so if we're going to go back and again
i'm going to do that right after header
but it doesn't really matter where you
do that i'm going to go with nav logo
and let's do that trick we'll go with
background and then let's add the red
one and you'll notice that yes these
ones so the link not the logo but the
link
is in one line with the button but not
the logo that is sitting inside of the
link and in order to fix that we simply
need to set our logo to be in display
flex
and then in order to place the image in
the center we simply need to go with
align items and then center again please
keep in mind we're talking about the
logo
so we're talking about the link and then
we set it up as display flex line items
in the center so now the actual image is
in the center now of course you can
clearly see that they're actually in one
line so now we want to remove the
background we don't need it anymore and
once we fix this tiny bug we're done
styling the navbar for the small screen
layout
all right it looks like we're done with
initial navbar css but before we worry
about styling the big screen layout
let's quickly knock out the toggle
functionality
and as i said note if you're not
comfortable with javascript you can
simply copy and paste the code from the
final directory and the idea is
following on a small screen you want to
hide all the links by default
and we'll do that by setting up the
height
0 in nav links and in order to show them
we'll create a new class
with the current height of the now links
and lastly in javascript we'll toggle
the nav links by adding and removing the
show links class
so the end result should look something
like this
where if i make my screen size smaller
because notice we have the button and
once we click we show the links and once
we click one more time of course then we
hide the links and like i already
mentioned the plan is following where
we'll find the nav links
there it is we have our to do
and before we do anything before we set
height 0 i actually want to check the
height of the networks so let's open up
the dev tools we're looking for the
elements and more specifically we're
looking for now links and i can see that
the height for nav links is
309.79 pixels
and once i know that info i'll create a
class i'll say show
links
and in there we'll set up the height to
be exactly that whatever we have right
now for the networks and in my case i'm
going to go with 310 pixels and once i
have this height
now of course i want to go to the nav
links and like i said by default we'll
hide them so say here height is equal to
zero
then we also need to set up the overflow
hidden otherwise you can clearly see
that we can still see the links so let's
go over here
overflow hidden and we also want to add
the transition because when we'll be
toggling i actually want that toggle
effect to happen over time not instantly
so therefore we'll go here with
transition and we'll just be looking for
the css variable the transition one and
once we have all of this in place we can
actually test it out by just adding and
removing the class the show links one in
the devtools and then of course we'll
navigate to the javascript file and add
a functionality there as well so let's
go to the big screen i always find it to
be easier working there so let's inspect
and of course i'm looking for the nav
links element over here and then just
click on the class
and right next to the nav links just go
with show links and what you'll notice
the moment you press enter of course now
we can see the links and if i remove the
class then you can probably already
guess that we won't be able to see the
links and effectively the only thing we
need to do right now
is just navigate to the javascript file
so let's go to the directory the
javascript one we're looking for app.js
and in here we'll start with simple
hello world
and then back in the index html
we want to set up the script tags so
let's say here script and as far as the
source again we're pointing to the
javascript folder and then the app.js
and if you can see the hello world in a
console then of course we're moving in
the right direction
and as far as the app.js you can select
the nav link snap button directly but i
always like to set up a function
that gets me that element and if the
element doesn't exist so essentially if
i get back to null then i just throw the
error it might seem like an overkill on
a small project
but i still decided to share the
functionality so in here we want to go
with const get element
and then we'll pass in the selector so
this is going to be either the nav links
or nav button or whichever element you
want to select and then first let's go
with const element so now we'll select
it and we'll say document and then query
selector and now we pass in the selector
and you probably already know that e and
vanilla.js
if there is no element so if i pass in
some kind of selector that doesn't point
to an element of course i'll get back to
now so i'll say here if element exists
and only if it exists then i'll return
the element otherwise i'll throw the
error and i'll just say throw and error
and of course i'll pass in some kind of
message in this case i'm going to go
with template string i'll say please
double
check your
class names
and we'll go with there is no
and of course now i'm looking for that
selector
and let's add a class here and once i
have the function of course we can test
it out where i'm going to go with const
links so now i'm selecting the nav links
and i'll pass in the class of nav links
and if i don't see anything in the
console then of course we are in good
shape now if i'll add some class name
that doesn't point to an element then of
course we'll have please double check
your class names
there is no blah blah blah class
hopefully that is clear so now of course
we can set the proper class here copy
and paste we're going to be looking for
nav btn in this case and of course we
also need to change the name here so nav
btn
and then dom
and then let's just add a event listener
on a button
the click event and then every time we
click the button we'll toggle the
showings class so we'll add and remove
class on the links element so let's say
over here now btn then add
event listener
and then we'll be listening for click
events
and of course we need to pass in the
callback function and as far as the
logic will simply go with links
classlist
and then toggle so classless is the
property and there we have toggle method
and here we just need to say which class
we want to toggle keep in mind that in
here you don't need to pass in the dot
we already know that we're talking about
the class so you simply need to provide
the class value and the moment i save i
can see that i have
no bugs in the console which is always a
good sign and then of course notice as
we're clicking we're toggling the links
so if you want to test it out on a big
screen of course you can do that and
you'll clearly see that the moment i
click
i show links over here notice how we're
again adding this class of course in
this case we're not doing this manually
and then once we click one more time
then we hide the links and before i let
you go let me just say that i'm fully
aware that we are cheating a little bit
simply because if we change the amount
of links our functionality is not going
to work as expected because keep in mind
that back in the main css we're actually
hard coding this height value so of
course
as we're going to be adding more links
or removing the links
our functionality is not going to work
as expected
and if you took my javascript course you
probably worked on a project where we
covered the proper toggle functionality
but since it's not the main focus of the
project
i decided to take this route instead
all right and once we have the dongle
functionality in place i think i can
close the app.js and now of course we'll
focus
on a big screen layout so essentially
that's the look that i'm shooting for
once we get to the big screen i want all
of them in one line
links are going to be on left hand side
and then the contact one is going to be
all the way on right inside and in order
to do that we just need to come up with
some kind of value for the media query
and in my case i'm going to go for 992.
just keep in mind that of course i'm
zoomed in so technically it's not going
to happen exactly at 992.
so let's go with media screen
and then we'll be looking for min width
so min width and as far as the value
like i said i'm going to go with 992 and
the first thing that i want to do is
hide the nav button so let's just target
the class nav btn and we're gonna go
with display
and none so once we get to the big
screen i don't wanna show the button so
of course
once we get past 992 notice we don't
have the button that's the first thing
we want to accomplish
after that we want to go with nav bar
and we want to set the height to b6 rams
if you remember on a small screen the
nav header was 6r games correct now in
this case that's not what i want
therefore i'll go with navbar and then
we'll set height to be 6 rms and again
if you want to check it out of course
add that background already and you'll
see how it's going to look like then we
want to go with nav center and i want to
set up display flex why because i want
all of them in one line keep in mind
that of course for the links we'll still
have to set them up as display flex as
well otherwise it's not going to work
they'll still be flex direction column
but as far as nav center yes
i want the header i want the links e in
one line therefore will go here with nav
center
and then we're looking for display and
of course we'll set it equal to flex
then we want to align them vertically in
the center so go with align item center
after that we have the nav header and
this is the case where of course we'll
target that
we'll say nav header i don't want the
height to be 6 rms so let's just say
here auto so essentially this is going
to be the height of the actual content
and then let's go with margin and right
so this is just going to create a little
bit of distance in between the links and
nav editor so now if i navigate to the
big screen this is what you should see
now of course we cannot see the links
and this is exactly what we're going to
work on right now where essentially we
need to understand that
if i take a look at the nav links i set
height to be equal to zero
so what happens
if i hide the links on a small screen
which of course is exactly what i have
right now i'm not going to be able to
see them on a big screen so now notice
if i show the links on a small screen
i'll also see them on a big screen now
of course the layout is still the mesh
don't worry about that that's not what
we focused on what i want to showcase is
that if we hide them on a small screen
we're not going to be able to see them
on a big screen why well because this
height is set to zero
and in order to fix that we simply need
to target the class first some nav
links and we want to go with height auto
and now you'll notice that even though
the links are hidden on a small screen
once we get to the big screen we set the
height and we can see the links now of
course let's work on this layout because
it is a mess
and i simply want to change my flex
direction and i want to set it equal to
row so now of course they'll be in one
line
then i want to align them in the center
vertically because i have the button and
i have the links just in case there are
some differences there and also
notice over here the nav center
is taking up all of this space
and then when it comes to header it just
has its own width correct and the same
goes for the knight links but i want to
change that essentially since nav center
is taking up all of this space i want my
links
to take up the remaining of the space
and the way we set that one up we just
go with with
and we set it equal to 100
and yes the moment nothing changed over
here don't worry we'll work on that a
little bit later but now if we take a
look at the links notice they're
actually spanning all across so i have
my nav center that is still display flex
and now the nav links are spanning all
across again
if you want to test it out just go with
background and red and you'll see that
of course now the links are taking up
the remaining space and if i remove that
with hundred then of course it's not the
case now of course what i want
is to style those nav links specifically
because if you remember there are quite
a few styles coming from the small
screen and i actually want to override
them so i'll go with enabling so now i'm
targeting that one specific link and i'm
going to go with padding 0 since we
added some padding on a small screen
then we want to go with border top and
we'll set it equal to none then as far
as the margin since i want some distance
in between we're going to go with margin
right and we'll set it equal to 1 rem
and as far as the font size i'm going to
go with one rems and then lastly when it
comes to that contact link since i want
to place it all the way on the right
hand side we'll simply go with margin
left and we'll set it equal to auto and
what you'll notice is that we have the
header we have the links and of course
the contact link is all the way on the
right hand side and probably the biggest
gotcha is that height zero where
essentially again on a small screen we
set it equal to height zero so of course
once we get to the big screen
if we're hiding those links on a small
screen we need to show them and
therefore we set height equal to auto
and with this in place we're done
styling the navbar so now of course we
can move on to our next task all right
and once we're done with the navbar
let's set up a structure for all our
pages now before we do that though let
me just quickly mention that if you're
bothered with the small margin on a
contact one you can simply go back
and then add here margin and of course
we're looking for
margin right in this case and we can set
it equal to zero because of course all
the links get this margin right so
if we remove it then of course we'll not
have that space all the way on the right
hand side
and as far as the structure we want to
set up the page class
and then we also want to set up the
footer so this is going to be structure
for all the pages and then in different
pages of course we'll add different
content but all of them will have the
navbar we'll have the footer as well as
the page and you'll see once we get
there so first let's go back to
index.html and then right after the nav
we have end of nav and let's just say
here main or page or whatever so some
kind of comment copy and paste and we'll
say end of main and now let's set up a
main element and let's add a class of
page
and then after the main one this is
where we want to set up a photo so let
me go here with footer and then i'm
going to go with footer element
and as far as the class since there
might be a footer also in some kind of
card or something like that i always
prefer setting it up explicitly as page
footer but of course this is the
preference technically you can just
select the footer in the css and you'll
still be in good shape and as far as
footer i want to go with paragraph here
then we'll go with special html
character
so i'm going to go here with ampersand
and then we'll say copy so of course now
we'll get that copyright sign and then i
just want to set up the date now for
time being we'll hard code that and then
later on in video we'll actually set up
the javascript code as well so let's go
here with id and date so that's what
we'll use in javascript and like i said
for now we'll just hard code we'll say
2021
and then right next to the span we'll
set up another one so still within the
same paragraph we'll go with second span
and here let's add class and we'll say
footer logo
for logo
and then let's just write whatever is
the logo of the site so in my case it is
simply recipes but of course you can add
different logos as well
and then
right outside of the span but still
within the paragraph we'll go with built
by
and i'm just going gonna use a shameless
plug
and i'll set up a link back to
johnsmilk.com so go with href
then i want to go to the big screen and
i'm gonna be looking for johnsmilk.com
i'm gonna grab the href copy and paste
and of course now i have a link and
let's just type over here coding addict
so that should do it for the html part
for the structure for all the pages now
of course we just want to swing back to
the main css and i'll grab this comment
one
and then copy and paste and we'll set up
one for footer as well so let me copy
this one copy and paste and then let's
set up one for footer
and you know i'm actually going to copy
paste one more time
that way i can set up the next comment
as well and for the sake of simplicity
i'm just going to leave it blank
now we'll actually start with a footer
and only then we'll worry about the page
and you'll see in a second why for time
being what we can do on a page is just
set up our famous background red since
that way we'll clearly see what we're
styling and let's just start by
targeting the page footer
so let's say here page footer and i want
to go with height equals to for ariums
so add some kind of height then we'll
also go with text align center so now
all the text is going to be in the
center then we want to add background
and let's go with css variable so in
this case i'm looking for the value of
black and then of course we also want to
add some kind of color so in this case
we'll go with color and we're looking
for the white one so now of course all
the text is white apart from the link
but i'm noticing here that of course i
have the height
but i'm not placing the content in the
center so actually a better approach is
removing this text line center and we'll
go to display
and we'll set it equal to flex and then
let's align them in the center
vertically and also justify content
which of course is going to do that
horizontally so both justify content as
well as the online items are set to
center
now we still have some default margins
and therefore we'll target the footer
and more specifically paragraph and
we'll say margin bottom is equal to zero
and once we have that i just want to add
colors
to the link
as well as the logo and in order to
accomplish that we simply go with footer
logo
then comma and then we'll go with page
footer
and then link
and now of course i want to go with
color
and we'll be looking for the primary one
so once we set it up of course now the
logo as well as the link have this
primary color and if i take a look at
the complete project
that's what i'm shooting for
now the next thing that i want to do is
set up the page height because if you
notice at the moment of course yes we do
have the nav bar we have the footer but
i actually want the page to take up the
remaining space and how we can do that
well we can use mid height and we'll use
the call function because both the
navbar as well as the footer have some
kind of height
and first let's start with some kind of
width
so in here let's say background red and
we'll go with width and width always
will be 90 percent of the screen size so
that's why we have view with units
and of course i also want to set up some
kind of max width and this will be equal
to my css variable so let's go over here
with max with and eventually what you'll
notice
is that the content of the page
is going to be aligned exactly like the
navbar because if you remember we also
use the max width in the nav center so
that's why both of them will be in one
line now of course we have no content so
you cannot see that yet but trust me
eventually it's going to be there then
we want to go with margin 0 and auto so
now we'll always place it in the center
and then i also want to add a little bit
of padding on the top so say here
padding top and let's just go with two
rams now of course we can clearly see
our red box which essentially is going
to be our page and lastly what we want
is set up that mid height so for all the
pages there's always going to be this
mid-height and i want this to be hundred
percent but i want to subtract the
height of the navbar as well as the
height of the footer so we can do that
by setting up mid-height then we'll go
with calc function and let's just go
with 100 view heights so this is going
to be 100 percent of the screen
minus and then of course we want to add
600 yams plus
the four rms and what you'll notice that
regardless on the screen size this is
going to take at least 100 percent
of the height
now of course if we'll add more content
it's going to be bigger and you'll see
that in lighter pages but at least
minimum
it's going to be 100
minus the navbar as well as the footer
and then before we add that to all the
pages i actually want to go to the
app.js
i want to target the date element
and i just want to showcase how we can
add this dynamically so for time being
let's just remove this
code essentially let's just remove the
current here because we're not going to
be hard coding that and i want to swing
back to app.js
and in here right after the nav button
we'll go with const date so now we're
selecting get element and of course i'm
looking for that id i'm going to say
date
and in here we'll just go with const
current year
and if you want to convert here in
javascript we just simply go with new
date we invoke it and we have a function
by the name of get full year so now of
course we just need to go with date so
that's the element then text content and
that is equal to the current year so
this way we'll always have the current
year we won't have to hard code this and
then lastly once we have this structure
i actually want to take it copy and
paste and set it up in all the pages
and before you get mad about it before
you get mad about the fact that we still
need to copy and paste in all the pages
let me just say one more time
since we're just using straight up html
and css we don't we don't have any
concept of templates or components that
we have in react so yes
if we have multiple pages there's really
no other way
and of course once we set up structure
for all the pages
then we'll worry about index.html and
then one by one we'll add code meaning
the html and css to rest of the pages so
once you have the structure
since we'll use it and all the pages and
since we have all the correct links
whether that
is for css or for javascript i want to
take all this
and then one by one i want to add it to
all the pages because in here yes we
have some boilerplate code but
essentially what we want is just select
everything and then overwrite with our
current code that is coming from the
index.html and of course the only thing
you need to do over here is just change
the title and since this is 404 page
since this is an error page i'm going to
go here with error and if you want add
more text of course you can do that but
in my case i won't
and then just so i can understand what
is happening
where i have the page i'll also add a
heading 1
and i'll say error page and again we
need to do that for all the pages we
want to do that for about contact
recipes single recipe tag template and
tags and of course i'll stop the video
because i don't think it's very useful
for you to watch how i do to hold the
pages but i strongly suggest you do the
same because that way it's going to be
easier later on when we set up the pages
and once you copy and paste our page
structure
your website should look something like
this
where in all the pages you'll have the
navbar you'll have the footer you'll
also have the page
with a heading one with the name of the
page and of course a title
that matches whatever is the file name
over here
and essentially from the navbar you
should be able to navigate to all the
pages
as well as d404 so the 404 of course is
the one where we need to go to the url
and let's just say 404 html and
effectively this is an error page
if the user is looking for some kind of
resource on a server that doesn't exist
and just to showcase how is that going
to look like in the actual dynamic
application
let me just find here gatsby version
three so this is the original project
notice if i'm looking for some kind of
page that doesn't exist let's say users
page we'll see this 404 so that's the
one that we'll set up here in the error
page and with all of this in place now
of course we can keep working on a
project and up next
i actually want to work on a homepage
where we have this banner all right and
once we have all the structure in place
now of course let's worry about our hero
and essentially what i want is some kind
of div with a background and for that
background we'll use the image and then
we'll also place a text in a center
and as far as the html we want to go to
index.html so of course this is going to
be our homepage and then inside of the
main let's just add here a comment
let's say that we're going to be looking
for the header element here and then
let's go with the actual header element
with the class of hero
and inside of it we're going to go with
hero container and hero text and you'll
see in css
why we have this nested structure so
let's go with hero container
and then inside of that hero container
we're going to go with hero text and
then in there we'll place the heading
one
with some kind of text again in my case
it's going to be simply recipes and then
right below it will go with a subtitle
and now one will be no fluff
no fluff
just recipes
and once we have the html in place now
of course we want to navigate to main
css
let's open up the main css here we have
already a comment
so let's just say here hero i guess
and before we do anything maybe let's
just copy and paste so we don't worry
about the next one
so copy and paste and then let's just
say here hero and in here i just want to
set up some kind of height for my hero
and i guess i'm going to go with height
of
40 view heights essentially again 40
of the screen so let's go with height
and once we have that let's add that
background so let's go over here with
background url and we'll be looking for
the image and in this case i'm looking
in the assets and we'll go with main
jpeg but of course we want to place it
in the center we want to make sure it
covers everything and also there's no
repetition of course we can do it a long
way but there's also a shortcut where we
go to center cover
and then we set it equal to
no repeat so once we do that of course
we should see the image
now what i want is to add a border
radius so i want rounded edges and i
also want to add a little bit of margin
in the bottom
so let's go here with margin bottom and
we'll set it equal to two rems and also
i want to add that board radius so let's
just go with border radius and set it
equal to our bore radius global property
now in order to set up the look where i
have a text right in the center
and as you notice here
the background is actually a little bit
darker so
there is some kind of overlay on the
image we'll actually set this one as
position relative position relative and
then the hero center
so this enclosing div this is where
we'll set up position absolute and then
we'll use display flex to place a text
in the center so let's keep scrolling
and we're gonna go with hero container
and like i said we're gonna go with
position absolute and since the parent
is position relative now of course we're
setting up everything based on a parent
and then here i just wanna have a width
100
height of 100
and then let's just set up top and left
to be equal to zero so top and left both
are equal to zero and once we have all
of this in place
now of course let's add that
overlay and we do that by going with
background and then we're looking for
rgba and i'm just gonna go with zero
zero zero
zero
0.4
so rgba now this gives me 0.04
that's not what i want so essentially
notice how the background right now is
darker so we added the overlay on top of
the image and of course if we go really
dark then of course it's going to be
harder to see the image so therefore i
go here with rgba and as a result i can
nicely control this color so the darker
you'll go here of course the darker the
overlay is going to be and the reason
why we want to set that up is because if
we don't do that then of course with
white text
it's going to be hard to see the text
that's why we want to set up the image
we want to add the overlay and we want
to add some dark color to it and then
we'll make the text white
so right after the background we can
probably go with border radius since at
the moment our image has the border
radius but not the container so let's go
with border radius
and we'll set it equal to the border
radius property and then if i want to
place the text in the center we want to
go with display flex
line item center so that's going to be
for vertical and just for content
is going to be full horizontal center
and then we want to target the hero text
so that's going to be a div inside of
that container
so here are text and let's just set up
text align center because you notice
even though the hero text is in the
center the actual text inside of it is
not therefore we go text align and we
set it equal to center so now of course
everything is in the center and let's
also add that white color so let's go
with our css variable and of course the
name is white and then the very last
thing that i want to add is the media
query for
768 pixels
and once we get to that screen size i
wanna make the font size for heading one
four rems and set the margin bottom to
be equal to zero so in here let's go
with media screen
and of course we're looking for some
kind of value in this case i'm gonna go
with and min width and 768 pixels and
once we get to the screen size like i
said we're gonna go with hero text and
heading one and let's just go with font
size four rems
and then let's set up the margin bottom
to be equal to zero
and once we have everything in place
let's navigate here and this is going to
be the look on a big screen
and if we make this smaller of course
this is going to be the look on a small
screen now as always i'm massively
zoomed in so technically if you take a
look at the small screen it's going to
look something like this
and once we have our hero in place now
of course we can focus
on our recipes where we'll have two
column layout on one side we'll have the
tags and then on the other side we'll
have the cards beautiful and with our
hero out of the way now let's tackle the
big beast the recipes layout where we've
got a two column layout with tags in one
column and cards in the other now since
we'll reuse this layout in multiple
pages please take your time and don't
rush with this one
better to take more time right now than
chase some silly spelling errors later
and from my part i'll probably be even
more annoying than usual by repeating
the same things over and over since in
here we have the nested layout so it can
get tricky and therefore i think it's
important that i basically keep
repeating the same things
and we'll also split this one into
multiple videos just so we can build
everything step by step the good news
once we're done with the recipes it's
pretty much smooth sailing from here on
out and effectively we want to go back
to the index.html of course we're
looking for the main and you want to
place this one in the main so not
outside the main not inside of the
footer you still want to place it in the
main and therefore i'll add bunch of
comments here as well again we will
reuse this one so it's much easier if
you have clear comments where the next
section starts or the element and
hopefully you get the gist so let's go
here with end of header
and then we'll add another set of
comments and let's just go
with recipes container
container and i'll do it over here as
well and let's just say end off
end of recipes container
and then we're going to go with section
with the class of recipes container so
section
recipes
container and inside of the container
we'll have two major things
we'll have a tags container so i'm
talking about this column over here so
this is going to be our tags and then
we'll have recipes cards and of course
there's going to be more content but for
now let's just set up those main
elements and again we'll place bunch of
comments let's say tag container
and then we'll copy and paste of course
and here we'll say end of tag container
and as far as the tags well we'll just
go div with a class of tags
container so if you want maybe let's add
an s here as well just so it makes a
little bit more sense
and then we have a recipes list
so these are going to be those cards
and in this case i think i can just copy
and paste
and we'll just change things around
where i want to select all the tags here
and let's say recipes
and instead of container this is going
to be a list so let's say here list so
that's going to be the structure
for this container so a recipes
container then tags container where
we'll have the tags
and here of course we'll have the cards
the recipe cards and now one by one
let's add more content
and as far as the recipes container
we're going to have a heading 4
with the text of recipes
and then also have a div with a class of
tags list
and essentially in here i'm just going
to have links now since again this is
html and css project we'll simply
navigate to the page to the tag template
page and we'll display these recipes
when you're talking about the dynamic
project the one that we set up in gatsby
of course in here we navigate to the tag
of course we display that one specific
or multiple recipes that are associated
with that tag keep in mind that in this
case of course it's not going to be
dynamic we'll just have one page and
we'll navigate there
and content will always be the same but
when it comes to dynamic project of
course you click on a tag and then you
only display the recipes that are
associated with that tag and hopefully
you can already see
that when it comes to layout it
resembles a lot to what we have here in
recipes list so this is what i'm talking
about where we will reuse this layout
and some parts of this layout quite
heavily around the project so let's make
sure that we set up everything correctly
so back in the index.html i have tags
container i have heading four
and in here i wanna go with tags list
and essentially these are just going to
be linked to the tag template page again
they're not going to be dynamic all of
them will point to the same page and
essentially in there we'll just have
static content and as far as the href we
want to go with tag template html and
here let's just add some different
values so i'm going to go with beef
and i'll say one
so what i'm trying to say here is that
there's one recipe that has the tag of
beef and of course we'll just copy and
paste and change these values around so
for breakfast
we'll go with two
then four carrots we'll go with three
carrots we'll go with three
and here of course we'll have the
generic one the food one which is for
and again
not to be redundant but in a normal
project of course this is coming from
the database so this info is coming from
database and it changes it is dynamic
the more items you add of course you'll
display different info in here just html
and css project so of course we're just
hard coding and when it comes to recipes
list we want to set up those cards so
we're done with tags container it should
look something like this
and then back in the recipes list we
want to set another comment and we'll go
with single recipe so this is going to
be that card and we'll copy and paste so
we'll say and off single recipe and here
i want to go with link
now this link is going to go to single
recipe page and essentially
this page probably is going to be the
last we set up because there's also
quite a bit of work over there but the
idea is that this goes to the tag page
but then this one goes to that single
recipe whatever it is again in our case
it's going to be hard-coded so if you
take a look it's all the time display
the same info here but in general when
you have dynamic project of course you
display a different recipe hopefully
that is clear
and as far as the href will go with
single recipe html
and we'll right away add a class here of
a recipe and then inside of it we want
to go with image
and as far as the source well it's going
to be in the assets and we'll start with
recipe one then two and i believe we'll
have four so
you can already guess that of course in
the assets we have a recipes folder and
in there i have recipe one recipe two
three and four so let's start with the
first one so again we have here a image
tag now let me close the sidebar and
we're gonna be looking in the assets and
then more specifically recipes and then
in there we have recipe one jpeg now as
far as the alternative let's just say
food
and then i also want to right away add
classes so have the generic img class
remember that was set in global styles
as well as recipe
img so that's the class i want to add
and then right after my image
and let me close this one and right
after my image let me go with heading 5
and i'm going to go with some kind of
text
and let me just say so i'm going to go
with this one
and then
i'm also going to go with prep time and
cook time so i'm going to set up a
paragraph with the text of prep and
again in this case we're hard coding of
course and we're going to go with 15
minutes then a vertical bar
and of course we'll go with cook
and this is going to be equal to 5
minutes let me save it let me take a
look
that should be the look on a big page
okay looks about right and now we simply
want to copy and paste this one
and just change the heading five so i'll
leave the paragraph exactly the same but
since i'm going to be changing the
pictures i'll also change the text over
here and if you want to see the final
text just navigate to complete project
and of course this is what we're
shooting for so these are the titles of
our recipes so let me just take here
where i have the starting comment
and select everything
including the ending comment and now of
course we want to copy and paste three
times so one two and three and now the
only thing left to do is scroll up okay
that's our first recipe
and then we'll look for the next one and
we'll just change
the image so now of course this is going
to be recipe number two and as far as
the text
these are gonna be greek ribs
ribs and let me just save it
so i can see that yep that looks about
right then we have vegetable soup
and that is gonna be recipe number three
and of course i'll change the text here
as well
and last one will be banana package and
of course we want to change the image as
well so in this case we're looking for
recipe number four so if i take a look
at the big screen should look something
like this
and of course we have the recipes so
these are going to be our tags and then
we have those four recipe cards
wonderful we're actually done with html
so now let's navigate to main css
and of course let's set up the styles
and like always we'll start with the
small screen of course and then we'll
worry about the big screen layout i have
my comment here so let me copy and paste
and here i'll just write recipes
and then in order to help us i'll add
some boris again just so we have
understanding of what's happening so in
here let's go with recipes container
so that's going to be that main
container and here we'll go with display
grid
and if you remember by default it's
going to be a one column layout so
that's exactly what i want on a small
screen but eventually keep in mind that
this is going to be a two column layout
correct so we might as well set up the
gap right now for both
four rows as well as the columns again
i'm talking about the parent container
where i have the recipes and the cards
and therefore i'll go with gap here and
i'll say two rems
and we'll set it up as one rem again at
the moment we'll only use one because we
have one column layout but then
eventually once we have two columns
essentially once we set up the media
query of course then we'll use both of
the values hopefully that is clear and
like i said in order to help us let's
just go with two pixels solid and red
just so you can see what's happening so
that's going to be my main container
then we want to go with tags container
again that is for the tags so tags
container
and essentially we want to set up right
away border just so we can see what
is happening so what we're styling
and in this case i'm going to go with
blue and once i save i should see over
here that that is my text container
and as far as the styles
i actually want to place it all the way
in the bottom so i want to change the
order notice over here in the index.html
what do i have first of course i have
the tags correct i have my tag container
and only then i have the recipes list
and i'll send out let me just change
this one as well so it's not going to be
a recipes container we'll go with
recipes list so end of
recipes list just so we have a little
bit more clarity
and then what i'm trying to do on a
small screen
is to actually change the order so
notice here i have the hero first and
then i have the cards and all the way in
the bottom i have the recipes i mean
it's not a big deal you can technically
keep it at the top but it's actually my
preference to change the order and if
you remember by default
all of them have order of zero so if
you'll add order of one you'll notice
that the recipes are going to be all the
way in the bottom so essentially we have
the recipes list still with order of
zero and we just changed the order over
here now of course once we get to the
big screen we'll change it back again
but that's a different scenario
then we want to go with display flex and
flex direction column
now again keep in mind that i'm talking
about the parent container
for the heading 4
as well as the links so for both of them
now when it comes to links there's going
to be another nested layout but we'll
worry about that one a little bit later
so let's just say here display flex then
we want to go with flex direction and
we're going to be looking for the column
and eventually we want to set up the
batting in the bottom as well and we'll
set it equal to three rems so it should
look something like this
then we want to go with recipes list and
then we'll swing back to the tags so
let's go over here with recipes list and
again by default this is going to be a
one column layout and we'll do that just
by setting up display grid
and then we'll right away set up the gap
of
two rems and one rem and again this is
going to be the same as with the main
container where since we have one column
layout of course we're not at the moment
using both values but how the recipe
list eventually is going to look like
well it's going to be a three column
layout correct so therefore i right away
add that gap property with both of the
values and also i want to do the same
thing where i'll add the padding bottom
equal to three rems
then we want to swing back to the tags
so i set up pretty much the major styles
for recipes list now i want to worry
about the tags
and first let me scroll down just so i
can see what's happening and we're going
to go with tags container then we're
looking for heading 4 of course and
we'll add a little bit of margin in the
bottom so say here 0.5 rms
and then as far as the font weight let's
just change it around and let's set it
equal to 500
after that i want to go with entire list
of course i'm talking about the actual
tags list and i'll make the screen size
bigger just because i have zoomed in
otherwise it's going to look funky and
we're going to go to tags list and in
here we want to go with display grid and
we'll right away set it up as a three
column layout so let's say grid template
columns and we're looking for one
fraction one fraction and one fraction
again keep in mind that of course this
is going to be a small screen layout
once we get to the big screen of course
we'll set it back to one column item
then we want to style the actual link so
let's say over here
tags list and of course i'm looking for
the link element as far as the text
transformation will capitalize it
then we want to set them up as display
block
and after that we want to set up the
color
and i'm going to go with my gray 500
here and also i'll add transition
because there's going to be a hover
effect so transition and then as far as
hovering
let me just speed this up by copying
and then i'll say hover and as we're
hovering i'm just going to change it to
primary so again copy and paste the
color and instead of gray
let's go with primary once we save we
should see that as we're hovering notice
of course we're changing the color of
the link then we want to go and style
the recipe now what is the recipe well
that is going to be our card so we're
pretty much
done with a tags of course apart from
the big screen and therefore i'll still
leave those borders i'll remove them at
the very very end
and you know what
actually let me look for the recipes
list and let me add the border here as
well
because i think it's going to be very
helpful later so let's say here green
let's save that one and yep of course we
can see where we have our columns
and like i said we're going to target
the recipe so that's going to be the
entire card recipe here and remember it
was a link so start with
display block
and then once we set this up now of
course i want to target the image so
each card has the image so let's target
it let's say a recipe and i believe the
class for the image was recipe img
and i'll set up the height and i'll go
with 15 rems like so then i'll add right
away a border radius
and we'll look for our css variable for
that of course it's a border radius and
as far as the margin well let's just set
up margin bottom
one rms we save that one and then we
want to go with a recipe and heading
five so of course it's gonna be the
title and also i want to style the
paragraph and then we're pretty much
done with a small screen so let's go
over here let's say a recipe and heading
5 like i said and we're looking for
margin bottom 0
then i want to make the line height
smaller so go with one if you remember
in global styles of course by default it
was bigger and then as far as the color
let's go with color and we're gonna go
with gray 700 so it's not going to be as
dark as the rest of our text it's going
to be a little bit lighter and then also
we have one for the paragraph so let's
say here recipe paragraph
and basically what we're looking for is
margin bottom to be zero because there
is some margin
as a default and then the same thing
line height will be equal to one and
that's usually the case when i'm dealing
with some kind of cards because you
don't want those massive line heights
then let's also add right away margin
top to be
0.5 rem's just so we get a little bit of
space as far as the color i'm going to
go with gray but i'm looking for 500 so
i'll just copy this one just so we can
save a little bit of time and then i
also want to set up the letter spacing
so letter spacing
and we're looking for the css variable
and there it is and with this in place
we're actually done styling the small
screen layout
and now of course we just need to focus
on multiple media queries wonderful
our small screen looks pretty good apart
from those borders which of course we'll
remove a little bit later so now let's
focus on the multiple screen sizes and
of course we'll do that setting up the
media queries so let me go here with
media screen and i believe we'll have
three of them so right away set them up
and then we'll just worry about the code
inside of them so let's just go with 576
pixels and then we want to copy and
paste this one two times
and then as far as the values one is
going to be for
992
and then last one will be for 1200
pixels so we set this one up
and then inside of the first one we want
to go with recipes list
so this is the actual list where we have
the cards keep that in mind i'm not
talking about the container i'm talking
about the recipes list where we have the
cards and i want to set it up as two
column layout so let's go over here with
recipes list
and then we want to go with grid
template columns and we'll set it up as
one fraction and one fraction now keep
in mind that if we scroll up and if we
take a look at the recipes list it is
already a display grid
correct so therefore i can right away
set up that column layout and i also
like to set up my images a little bit
smaller once they're side by side so on
a small screen
i mean 15 rams is pretty good but
once actually the screen size gets a
little bit bigger meaning starting with
576 and once i have the two-column
layout actually it makes a little bit
more sense to go with a recipe and then
img at least in my opinion of course you
don't have to but at least in my opinion
i always go with 10 rems basically i set
them smaller maybe sometimes bigger than
10 rms and hopefully you get the gist so
now let me navigate here to the big
screen just to showcase what's happening
so i'll make this one over here so this
is going to be our one column layout and
then once we get to the 576
of course this is going to be the look
so now we have that two column layout
hopefully that is clear and now we can
focus on
992. now at 992
we'll actually change the layout
for the entire container where we have
the tags as well as this recipes list
and the way we'll do that of course
we'll look for our media query that's
step number one and we're looking for
recipes and container now again
it is already display grid correct
starting with the small screen so the
only thing we really need to do is come
up with values for the columns and in my
case i went with 200 pixels so that's
for the tags that's the width of my
first column and then one fraction
basically to take up the remaining space
for the recipes list
and as far as the recipes list
well i have already a grid template
column set to one fraction one fraction
so i don't need to worry about that the
only thing that i want to set up here
and maybe i'll style the paragraph a
little bit differently as well but
as far as the tags container i want to
go with order and zero remember
on a small screen what was the order it
was one
and what was the result well the result
was that tags are all the way in the
bottom correct so they're after the
recipes list now of course once we get
to 992 i want this look i want actually
both of them side by side like this so i
need to place it
back where it belongs and of course i
can do that with order of zero
so let's go with tags and then list
let's set up or i'm sorry not tags list
my bad so tags container
first and we'll go with
order
and of course it's going to be zero and
then as far as the tags list of course
we have three column layout on a small
screen but
is that something we want over here of
course no we want one column layout
because now of course they will be side
by side now how we can achieve that all
we can go to tags
list and remember it is already display
grid
it already has the column layouts we
simply need to change it we need to go
with grid template columns and set it up
as one fraction
and lastly as far as the recipe i
actually want to go with paragraph font
size to be 0.85
rem so you can place it
at the very end or after the recipe it
doesn't really matter we'll go with
recipe paragraph
and let's just go with font size and
like i said we're going to be looking
for
0.5 rems let's save it and let's take a
look
and we can clearly see that this is our
main container
with a red border and then of course i
have blueboard for the recipes meaning
for the tags i'm sorry and then the
green one for recipes and as you can see
once we have a smaller screen then of
course we have this layout and once we
get over here beautiful now we have two
column layout and lastly once we get to
1200 pixels the only thing i really want
to do here is make the recipes list
a three column layout so let me swing
back
and we'll keep on scrolling and of
course at 1200 pixels we'll set up our
recipes list to be a grid template
columns and of course i'm looking for
three column layouts so i'm going to go
with one fraction one fraction and one
fraction and yes i'm fully aware that of
course we can write the repeat and all
that but in this case i just thought
that it's going to be quicker if i go
with one fraction and then as far as the
font size for the heading 5 i want to
set it up to be
1.15 rems
so i'm looking for a recipe
and since i already have for the
paragraph i might as well copy and paste
and essentially we want to go with
heading five here i believe it was
heading five and then we'll go with one
point one point fifteen rems let's save
that one and i need to navigate back to
the homepage here
and now let's take a look at our big
screen layout so essentially once our
screen gets bigger bigger bigger bigger
then of course we arrive at the three
column layout again this is going to be
the look on a small screen where we have
recipes list first
then we have the tags
then once we get to the
576 we have two column layout for the
recipes list
then once we get to 992 we have two
column layouts for the entire container
and we still have these two columns over
here for the recipes list and then once
we get to the big screen voila of course
now we have two column layout and here
we have three column layout so now of
course the only thing really left
is to remove those borders
so we have recipes list we have tags
container
and of course we have the recipes
container and with this in place we have
tackled the big beast congratulations
and of course we can move on to our next
step
not bad not bad essentially we're done
with our homepage so now let's knock out
the other pages as well we'll start with
an easy ones first like error and
recipes and eventually work on more
complex ones as well
and in this video i want to complete
three pages error page recipes page and
tag template page let's start with an
error and i know i already said this
before but essentially the 404 the error
page is if the server cannot find the
resource and in the gatsby project it's
going to look something like this or
again we go with a domain and then we
say error and of course that's going to
spit back the error page and actually if
you deploy this project the simple
recipes one it's going to work the same
way so even the html and css one on
netfly if you're looking for some kind
of page that doesn't exist since we have
the 404 of course we'll get back this
result now in our local development
that's not going to happen because the
extension is not that smart so in order
to see the page of course we'll have to
do that manually and the way we're going
to do that in the project is following
way we're first on a big screen
let's just type 404
html okay looks about right and then we
want to do the same thing so let me grab
the url
and just copy and paste and set it up on
a small screen as well so let me select
everything and then i'm looking for 404
so this is how it's going to look like
now when it comes to actual code of
course we want to navigate to 404 html
of course this is going to be our basic
structure for all the pages
and for the error page we simply want to
add one more class here since we'll add
a little bit more styles and let's say
here error and hyphen page and then as
far as the content we'll go over here
with section and then inside of the
section let's go with heading one
and let's say error and then lastly
let's go with heading three and we'll
say page not
and found so we save it over here and
now of course we just want to go back to
main css
again we're looking for our comment
we want to make sure that we have it
for the next one
and here i'll just say error
and as far as the code
essentially what we're looking for is
that class of error page
error page
and we'll go with text align
text line
and center like so
and of course we also want to add a
little bit of padding to the top and now
we'll be equal to 5 rms and when it
comes to a heading 1
let's just go with error page and
heading 1 and let's go with font size
and nine rems and you know what i messed
up a little bit where in the 404
we actually want to go with 404 the
numbers not the text of error and of
course we have our error page and once
that is done let me just navigate back
and in this case we're looking for
recipes page again in the nav bar look
for a recipes page and the same is going
to be on a big screen where we want to
go to the recipes page and what's really
cool we already have all the code for it
and you know where we'll get the code
over here take a look at the project so
this is our home page correct we have
the hero as well as the recipes layout
now what do you think is going to be in
recipes well
it's going to be pretty much the same
page
without the hero and again this is the
case where of course
normally this is some kind of template
or this is a component where you just
pass in the data so you don't have to
repeat yourself
but like i have already said million
times since we're working with just html
and css yes we'll have to copy and paste
and now of course let me go back to my
project
and i'm looking for the index.html and
this is the reason why i added so many
comments over here because we definitely
don't want to mess this up so we have
main over here correct with a class of
page then we have the hero so we can
actually collapse this one and what
we're looking for is this entire
container
now there's going to be a few more
instances where we'll just be looking
for
recipes list
this is not the case in the recipes page
you want to take the whole thing so
therefore i have these comments where i
have recipes container so copy
everything with the comment of recipes
container and then end of recipes
container that's what you're looking for
not the main now that stays over here
but the recipes container yeah take the
whole thing copy and now of course i
want to navigate to
recipes html
that's my page we keep on scrolling and
where we have the page the main one we
simply want to dump
our recipes layout so we just paste our
code over here let me save a recipe's
html
as well as the index one and now in our
project if we take a look voila we have
a recipes page done so this is going to
be our homepage and this is going to be
our recipes page and lastly in this
video i want to work on tag template
which also is going to look very very
familiar because if we take a look at
complete project either the gadsb1 or
just html and css which you'll notice
that if we navigate to a tag page what
do we have over here we have some kind
of hard-coded value which of course
again is not going to be the case in
dynamic project so this value will
change based on the tag now in this case
of course that's not the case we'll
always have this beef and then what do
you see over here
it looks like a list correct now where
do you think his list is coming from
over here
so that's why we set up the css in such
a way where it doesn't really matter
where we're placing that list
gonna have one column layout on a small
screen and then two column layout on a
bigger screen and then once we get to
the big screen it's going to be a three
column layout and in order to set that
up we simply go and look for
the tag template because remember in the
index.html or in the recipes now as well
when we're talking about those tags
links where do they navigate
tag template correct so therefore we
look for tag template and then again we
have the main one the class of page and
now of course we just want to change it
around a little bit where we'll start by
setting up a enclosing div
and we're simply doing that because i
want to place the heading 4 on top of
the rest of the content and we're gonna
go with beef so again we're hardcoding
some kind of value in this case beef and
now what you want is grab the recipes
list
from the index.html and i'm not gonna
repeat this whole spiel about why we're
copying pasting because i think i
already have mentioned this
way too many times during the project so
we're looking for recipes list
not the container we're looking for
recipes list take a look at the comment
and then look for the end one as well so
we're looking for and off and here i
probably messed it up or no sorry i
messed it up right now because i was
looking for a different comment again
we're looking for recipes list my bad
i mixed it up with the recipes container
and of recipes list that's the end point
we copy this one and back in the tag
template copy and paste and
congratulations we have three pages out
of the way so now of course we have the
homepage we have the recipes we have 404
and if we click on one of the tags
whether in the recipes page or in the
homepage where are we going to navigate
we're going to navigate to a tag
template where we'll display the tag
and list of recipes which again normally
would point to the recipes that are
associated with that tag and of course
you will be setting this up dynamically
normally but if we're just worried about
html css we have three pages out of the
way and of course we can focus on next
pages nice and up next i want to work on
the about page where effectively we'll
have two column layout
for the info as well as the picture
and then here at the bottom
again we're going to use a list
so technically these would be some
featured recipes that you want to
display again normally this is going to
be dynamic and you'll just pass in which
recipes you want to showcase but in our
case we'll just use our recipes list the
same one that we used in tag template
this one over here now in this case
however we only want to pass in three so
in the tag template we set up four but
in this case we'll just go with three
and effectively we will reuse that list
a few more times throughout the project
and the setup is going to be exactly the
same where again i'm looking for about
html i have my page so i do have the
structure
and here let's set up those recipes
first and you know we navigate here to
the about page as well so we can see
right away and once we set up those
featured recipes so the recipe list then
we'll worry about the rest of the
content
and inside of the page we want to go
with section
and then let's add about page so this is
where the info
as well as the photo are going to be
located
and then we want to go with another
section and then let's just call this
featured
recipes recipes and i actually don't
think that there are any styles with it
but let's just add the section with this
class
and then inside of it we want to go with
heading 5 and we're looking for feature
title and i'm sorry this is a class so
it's a featured
title and the only reason
why i'm adding here this class
is because
i want to place the text in the center
and again technically we can use this
feature recipes but if i remember
correctly the heading 5
was already in the card so that's why i
just went here with this class again
long story short basically we'll set
this one in the center and then as far
as the text let's just write look
at this awesome sauce and right below it
this is where we want to place all those
recipes so let's go back to index.html
and again we're looking for the recipes
list same deal now in this case of
course eventually we'll remove one of
the cards at least in my setup but if
you want of course you can keep all four
so we copy and paste the list we're
looking
for what we were looking for about html
correct
got a little bit lost over there and
then right after the heading 5 so within
featured recipes we want to copy and
paste and like i said my case i'll
remove one of them so i'll remove the
last recipe and once we save of course
we right away have our nice layout and
like i previously mentioned effectively
for this one for the heading 5 i just
want to place it in the center
so let's quickly go to
css and we're looking for feature title
i believe featured
and we're looking for title and we
simply want to go text align and center
so now of course it's going to be in the
center that's the recipes list part now
of course we just want to add that info
which is going to be here
in the about page and then we also want
to add a photo so let's set that one up
and in here we want to go with article
so this is where the info is going to be
located and then right below it we're
going to go with image and in this case
we're looking in the assets and then
more specifically we're looking for the
about one and then as far as the
alternative i'll just say pouring
salt
and we'll also add a few more classes to
the image
and those are following we'll go with
our img so the global one as well as
about img now when it comes to info
we're looking for heading two
and we'll just type some kind of text
and you know what in this case just so
we can speed this one up
look for this project or the other one
and basically just copy and paste the
text there's really no point to retype
that from the scratch and essentially i
got this text i believe from the hipster
epson which is my favorite place to get
lorem ipsum text effectively the dummy
text and then we want to go here with
the first paragraph so there will be two
paragraphs and i'm just getting the text
over here if you want you can simply
type lorem and then whatever amount of
characters so you can go here with lorem
and then let's say 20 or 10 or whatever
now in my case since i like that text
better i'm just going to copy and paste
that's my first paragraph and then of
course we're looking for the second one
and then at the very very very bottom we
also have the button so it's here button
the class will be btn
and then we want or not actually it's
gonna be a link my bad so let me remove
my apologies we're going to go with link
and this is going to be to contact html
and then we want to add the class of btn
and let's add a contact and since we
have already
global class for the btn that's where we
have to look and now of course we want
to swing back to
main css and we just want to apply a few
styles to about page and i'm just going
to keep this one on the bottom
because i like to keep things organized
that way but of course you can leave it
at the top as well and we're gonna go
with about page we're looking for the
heading two
so that's that main heading
with dummy text so about page heading
two and in here we'll say text transform
and we'll set it equal to none so
there's no transformation because for
all the headings we have that base
transformation then as far as the font
size i'll go with bold so i'll make it a
little bit bolder and then
in here let's also set up about page so
now of course i'm talking about that
section
and first i want to go with display grid
let's play grid and again by default
it's going to be that one column layout
but that doesn't stop me from setting up
the gap correct so again i have two rems
and then four rem's so this one of
course is going to be for my row and
then this one will be for my columns and
again at the moment we have one column
so it doesn't really matter
and then we also want to set up right
away some kind of padding here and let's
go with padding bottom three rms so
that's going to be added to this entire
thing so now of course we have distance
between the section the about page and
our featured recipes
and then we also want to target right
away the image and as far as the about
image well we have the class correct so
let's go with about hyphen mg and we're
looking for border radius and we use our
css variable for that and as far as the
height well let's set it up as 300
pixels now of course the height is a
little bit smaller and then we also want
to of course go with some kind of media
query because on a bigger screen we'll
have a two column layout so let's set up
a meter screen
and as far as the size let's go with and
and min width and my case again i went
with 992. that was just my preference
and we'll target the about page we'll
set up grid template columns grid
template comes as one fraction
and one fraction so we have two column
layout and then when it comes to rows
i'm going to go with 400 pixels now keep
something in mind where
we'll have only one row and essentially
what i'm doing i'm setting up the height
for my row and then i'll use the height
for the image and i'll set it equal to
100
so effectively as a result
my image is going to be the height of my
row so let's try it out over here we'll
say grid template rows and we're looking
for that 400 pixels
and then of course in here we'll go with
align items and we're placing it in the
center and i'll comment this one out in
a second just so you can see why we're
adding that one and let's go with our
about img
and then in here we'll go with height
and like i said we're gonna go with 100
so now what happens
on a small screen we'll have this look
so
once i make my screen size smaller it's
going to look something like this
and then once we get to 992
we have this two column layout and then
image is the height of my row and since
text is smaller now of course we're
placing it in the center now if i'll
comment this one out you'll notice that
text is all the way at the top so let me
put it back in there and of course we
have the about page completed as well
all right and as far as the next step we
want to go to contact page
and of course style this sucker
effectively here we have the same
featured recipes so we already know
where to get them the moment we have
them already in the about
and then when it comes to form
i mean most of it is already in a global
css so we should be done with this in no
time now at the moment of course in the
contact this is all i have a text with
contact page and of course we'll start
in the contact html that's what we're
looking for and like i said since i want
to simplify this first we'll go to about
html and we're looking for those
featured recipes
so take this section the featured one
and then just copy and paste and place
it in the contact page so take all this
code
navigate back to contact html and in
here we'll have two sections one is
going to be for that info
as well as the form so now let me close
the sidebar so let's start with that
section let's set up a section with a
class of
contact and then hyphen
container and then right after it will
copy and paste our featured ones so this
is what you should see on a screen the
featured recipes and of course we just
need to navigate up
where we have the actual container the
contact one and as far as the html
i mean there's not much there's some
headings some paragraphs and like i keep
saying form as well
and we'll start with an article so the
article is going to have some kind of
class
and we're going to go with contact info
in this case and then as far as the text
again i'm just going to speed this up
and i'm just going to copy and paste
from the final one so we're looking for
heading 3 copy and paste
and the same goes for these three
paragraphs that's it that's all we have
to do come up with paragraph and then
copy and paste
and the same goes for the rest of the
two so another paragraph here
and another set of text if you don't
like my text of course you can always go
with lorem
third paragraph
and then again we copy and paste the
text
and then right next to this article
we'll place another one
and this is where we'll place our form
and effectively we're looking for form
class as well as the contact form so
this is where we'll add a little bit
more styling and this is what you should
see on the screen
now i'll remove the action because of
course it's not going to be dynamic it's
not going to be a working form
and then inside it we're going to go
with form row
and then i want to add the label as well
as the input so we go here with label
and as far as the four attribute will go
here with name
and we'll also add a class of form
hyphen label again this is coming from
global css and then we'll just add your
name
then we'll save it and after that i'm
going to go with input the type will be
text
and let's just set up a name is equal to
name
and then we want to go with id
as well as the class of form input so
let's set it up over here
let's say id
and we'll set that one equal to name so
just make sure that both attributes the
id and four have the same value
and then we'll also look for the class
and that will be form input and once i
have my first row essentially what we
want to do is just add a comment and
we'll say
single
form
row
and i'll also add it over here at the
end of my div
and i'll say end of single row and now
of course we just want to copy and paste
i believe
two more times and i mean this is going
to be text area so maybe only once
so let's take this one copy and paste
and as far as the values
essentially everywhere where we have the
name we want to change it around to a
email so let me select all of the names
over here i'll go for email and the only
one that i need to change back of course
is this one so say name is also equal to
an email so if i take a look yep there
it is now of course we still need to add
some css but at least the basic setup is
working and then like i said we'll also
add a text area so let me keep on
scrolling here and after this row we'll
set up another one
and the class is exactly the same so go
here with form row and then inside of it
again another label in this case we're
looking for message
and class will still be a form
hyphen label
and as far as the text let's just write
message and this is where we want to go
with that text area so right after this
label
we'll go with text area and as far as
the attribute values let's set up both
name and id equal to a message
and then i'll remove the columns and
rows because of course we have already
all the styling in a global css so go
with form and we're looking for the
class of text area and once we save we
only need to add a button so right after
this div we'll go with button now in
this case it's going to be type submit
and then as far as the styling we'll go
with btn and btn hyphen block so now of
course the button is going to be
spanning
all across our form and line as far as
the text let's just go with submit
and once we have all of this in place
essentially we just want to navigate to
main css
so let me open up the file i'm going for
css i'm looking for main css i have the
about i think i need to copy the comment
as well
copy and paste and of course now i'm
looking for the contact page as far as
the value
contact page and i'll close the sidebar
here and what i want to do is set up
that form to be hundred percent so
remember by default we have some value
already on a form class and that's why
we added that contact form class
and here let's just say width to be 100
and as far as the margin i'm gonna go
with zero now don't worry of course
we'll use the container the contact
container to set them up side by side
and in fact it will do that right now
where we want to go back to the main css
we want to look for
contact
and then hyphen container
and here we'll go with display grid
now again on a small screen by default
it's going to be a one column layout but
that doesn't stop us from setting up the
properties for the gap so two rem's and
three rem's over here for the column and
then also add a padding to the bottom
and my case i'm going to go with 3 rms
so that's going to be the distance in
between these guys
and once we have all of this in place
now of course we just want to worry
about the media and we'll go with media
screen
and as far as the min width well let's
just set it up as
992. so men with 992
and pixels of course
and here let's just go with contact
container
and i'm going to be looking for grid
template columns and in this case i'm
going to go with one fraction so that's
for the text
that's for the left column over here and
then as far as the form i'm actually
going to hard code i'm going to say
450 pixels and then since i want text in
the center again i'm going to go with
that align items and center so let's go
back over here align items and we'll set
it equal to center and of course once we
have added the css we're done with the
contact form and now we can focus on our
next task
and once we have the contact form in
place now of course let's set up the
tags page which at the moment has only a
headache one
and what we're shooting for is this look
where we have the tags because these are
going to be dynamic in normal project
but in our case will just hard code and
then once you click on a tag then you
navigate to that tag template page
and of course this page we already have
that's why we have
all the recipes in place
and as far as the setup well in here let
me go back to the tags and i'll do the
same here and of course i'm already in
the page so i'm good
and we're looking for tags html we'll
close the sidebar for now we want to
remove that heading one we'll still keep
the page
and what we're looking for is the
section
and i'm gonna go with tags wrapper so
that's the class in here let's add a
comments so single and then tag and in
this case it's going to be end of single
tag
so end off single tag and then as far as
the setup it's going to be a link
class will be a tag and again we'll hard
code these values and i'm not going to
go over why we're hard coding the values
because i believe i have said that
already more than enough times during
this project
and where you want this link to navigate
well to the tag template remember that
represents
some specific tag and recipes
that have that tag and as far as the
proper path well it is tag template html
correct like i said we'll add a class
over here and i'll say tag and as far as
the values let's just go with heading 5
and we'll set it equal to beef
and as far as the amount of recipes well
it's going to be a paragraph with
one recipe and now what do we want to do
is just take
this one tag
copy and paste and let me take a look
how many i created i think i went with
five so let me see okay at the moment i
have one two three four
so let me copy that one more time and
now we just want to change these values
where again this is going to have two
recipes then we have dinner food and all
that so let me scroll up let me make
sure that i don't do anything with the
first one okay that one stays the same
for the second one we're looking for
breakfast it's gonna have two recipes
then we have one for carrots
and that is going to have i believe
three recipes then we have dinner and
food
with one recipe so dinner with four
recipes
and then food
with one
and once the html is in place now of
course let's just navigate to main css
and we want to set up another
new comment in here
so go here with tags of course
and this one will have a little bit more
css than the contact page because of
course with the contact page the biggest
one was the form but we already had a
bunch of styles in global css so let's
go here with tags page
and then i'm going to worry about my
wrapper and again it's going to be a one
column layout starting with the small
screen and then as the screen size
increases then we'll also change the
amount of columns but that doesn't stop
us from tags wrapper so that's the
entire wrapper then we go with display
grid and then i'm going to go with two
rem so that's going to be four to
columns and rows
and then adding the same deal we'll go
with padding bottom three rms
and once we have all of this in place
now of course we just want to worry
about that
one single tag
and the way we'll set up the css is
going to be following where we'll target
the tag
and we're looking for background and in
this case i'm going to go with gray and
500 so that's going to be the default
value then i also want to add right away
a border radius
and of course we'll use our css variable
for that after that we want to go text
align center so make sure that the text
is in the center color
white i think that should look good and
then as far as transition well let's
just use our css variable because when
we'll hover i'll change this color
and then we're pretty much done i just
want to set up the padding top bottom
0.75 rems and left and right 0
as i'm hovering over the tag
like i said i want to change it to a
primary color so let's just grab the
background one
and place it over here and instead of
gray 500 we'll go with primary 500.
let's save that one and notice as we're
hovering now of course we're changing
the color and we just want to add some
margins
0 to the bottom of heading 5 and a
paragraph because if you remember by
default we have them there so now of
course we'll remove those margins
and i want to do for both
for tag
paragraph as well as the heading so
therefore we'll go with tag paragraph
tag heading and then like i said we're
gonna go with margin bottom zero so both
of them have no margin there also i want
to increase the font weight for the
heading so let's set up the heading here
and we're going to go with font weight
and let's just set it up as 600
let's save and as you can see now of
course the font weight is a little bit
bolder
and lastly we'll have two column layouts
starting with
576 and then a three column layout once
we get to 992
and since i want to save a little bit of
time on a boilerplate we'll just copy
and paste and set it up over here
576.
we're targeting a tags wrapper of course
so the class is
tags and wrapper
and since we already have display grid
we're just going to go with crit
template columns
one fraction
and one fraction and of course the only
thing that's left to do
is to take this copy and paste
992
and then we'll have three column layout
and
just because some people probably are
annoyed i'm gonna go with repeat and
let's just say three one fraction so of
course that is the alternative syntax
that we can use and now let me navigate
to the big screen looking for tags
that's gonna be my layout and once i
click on a tag i navigate to a tag
template page and with this in place we
really need to worry about that single
recipe page
this one over here and don't forget
about this error page essentially when i
was setting up the structure for all the
pages i just forgot to change it to a
single recipe if you take a look at the
title of course it says single recipe
and as far as the single recipe page
it's going to look something like this
we're back in home we'll just click on
one of the recipes again we're hard
coding these values this is going to be
four banana pancakes
and at the top we have some kind of info
and then we have instructions
ingredients
and tools and in order to make it easier
again we'll separate these two
where in the first video we'll worry
about the info section
and then we'll deal with instructions
ingredients
and all that and we'll start by
navigating to single recipe of course
and in here first i want to remove that
heading one
we're not going to use that anymore and
the layout is going to be following
where again we have the page so this is
where we'll place
all of our content and instead of the
recipe page are going to be two sections
one is going to be recipe hero so
section with the class of
recipe
and hyphen hero and then the second one
will be the recipe content so that's
where the instructions tools and all
that is going to go in so we're going to
go here with recipe content and this is
the one that we'll work on in the next
video and in this video focus on this
one i'll start by placing some kind of
image like i said we are hard coding
this so we simply need to look for the
assets and then more specifically image
we want and in my case since i'm going
with banana pancakes i'm gonna go with
recipe number five i do to add some
classes here so start with our image
class and there's also going to be a
recipe hyphen hero
and hyphen img as far as the alternative
let's just say pancakes once we save we
should see the image which is always a
good sign right next to the image we'll
have that
second layout and this is going to be
the article and inside of the article
we'll start with heading two
and let's just write the name so banana
pancakes
and after that we want to set up some
kind of dummy text
and in this case i'm going to go with
paragraph and of course
like i did before
i'm just going to grab my hipster text
copy and paste okay i have my text
awesome
and then we'll have a recipe icons so of
course we're talking about
this column over here and the same goes
for tags and i guess more properly this
is a row with a three column layout or
of course we have the icons and then
here we have another row where we
display the tags
so let's keep scrolling
and as far as the recipe icons well we
want to go with div and instead of div
we'll set up some articles again we're
not placing in the recipe content so
let's just add here a comment recipe
content so we're clear where we're
setting this up so we want to look for
recipe hero
and then right after the paragraph we'll
go with div and let's just say recipe
icons we'll copy and paste and of course
at the moment i'm just setting up the
comment but eventually the div is going
to be there and the second one will be
recipe tags
and this is very useful once you start
troubleshooting trust me
adding these comments seems like a silly
idea but once in a while it really helps
you out
and then we'll look for dev like i said
we'll be looking for recipe
icons inside of it we're going to go
with one article and that's going to be
a single recipe icon
as far as the setup well we just need to
look for the icon and therefore i'll go
for i element the classes are following
f a s
and f a clock
and then let's just add some kind of
dummy text and that's going to be placed
in the heading 5 we'll say prep time and
also we'll have a paragraph with some
kind of hard-coded value in this case
that's going to be 30 minutes and now of
course i just want to take this article
copy and paste and change some values
around
where the second one will be f a r so
not f a s f a r it's not going to be a
prep time it's going to be a cook time
and here i'm just going to go with 15
minutes and then lastly we have the user
friends so that's the name of the icon
we're looking for
fasfa
then let's remove this piece and let's
say user
friends
and this is just going to be amount of
servings
servings
and we're looking for some kind of value
again so in this case i'm going to go
with 6 servings and lastly we want to
set up those tags so again make sure
that you don't place this in the recipe
icons make sure that you place here in
the recipe tags
so there with the class of recipe tags
and then as far as the content here
we'll go with tags so that's text
and this is going to be a link
now again we're navigating to a
tag template page therefore in my href
i'll type tag template
and html and we just want to set up some
dummy values so beef
save it and now you want to take the
link so don't take the tags
take just the link
i think i'm gonna copy and paste this i
don't know two more times
so three total
let me close the sidebar we just want to
change these values around second one
will be breakfast
third one will be pancakes and the
fourth one will be food
once we have the html for the hero in
place
now of course let's just navigate to
main css
we're looking for the last thing pretty
much
all the way in the bottom we'll have our
recipe template
so let's take this comment
copy and paste
and let's just say recipe
and template or single recipe you know
what
actually i'm going to go with single
recipe
single recipe page and we want to start
with that a recipe hero so recipe hero
and by default is going to be a one
column layout and we'll right away set
it up as display grid you should be
already familiar with that and i'll
right away also set up the gap to be
three arguments and once i have this in
place now i want to focus on that image
and remember the class was a recipe here
omg so recipe
hero
hero img
and basically i want to go with height
to be 300 pixels
so now it's a little bit bigger and as
far as the border radius well we have
the property for that we have border
radius property
and when it comes to the paragraph this
one over here i'm just gonna make it a
little bit lighter as far as gray color
so therefore i'll go with recipe info
and then i'm looking for paragraph and
of course we want to go with color
and i'm looking for gray and i'm going
to go with 600 so now it's a little bit
lighter then we can start focusing on
those icons so that's the next row
and as far as the setup there we'll go
with recipe
icons
and then i'm looking for display grid so
i want to set it up as a grid layout and
right from the get code it's going to be
a three column layout so go over here
with grid template columns and in this
case i'm going to go to repeat and as
far as the value i'll repeat three times
and one fraction so right from the get
go we have a three column layout and
again i've massively zoomed in so of
course normally it's going to look
something like this
and then once we have all of this in
place now let's add a little bit of gap
and in my case i'm going to go with 1rem
and we do want to add a margin top
bottom and therefore i'm going to go
with two rams and zero so nothing on
left and right
and when it comes to the text align i
want to place it in the center so let's
set up here text align and center
then we want to focus on the icon and we
can access that by recipe icons so
recipe hyphen
icons and i'm looking for eye element
and here i'm going to go with font size
1.5 rams and as far as the color
let's just go with primary so color
and we're going to be looking for our
primary one and i believe i'm going to
go with 500
then we want to target the heading 5 as
well as the paragraph and in this case i
think it's going to be faster if i just
copy and paste so we're looking forward
to heading 5 and we're also looking for
the paragraph and we just want to set up
the margin bottom to be equal to zero
and then font size to be
0.85
rems let's save that one and lastly i
want to target this recipe icons
paragraph and just add a different color
and in this case i'm going to go for
gray
and again i'm looking for that 600 value
so let's go here and let's say 600 so
that's going to be the color for that
paragraph
and then we just really need to worry
about those tags as well as the two
column layout once we get to the big
screen and in order to style the tags
we'll start with the actual container
and we'll set it up as display flex so
right from the get go it's going to be
display flex and then we'll align them
in the center vertically so align item
center then we'll make sure that it
wraps
if the screen size is not big enough so
flex wrap equal to wrap and then as far
as the font size i'm going to go with
0.7 and this is the interesting part
where i'm going to be looking for em
values so basically depending on my
container and i also want to add the
font weight
and in this case it's going to be equal
to
600 so the font weight of course is
going to be a little bit bigger and then
let's target those links
so of course i'm not talking about that
text talking about the link so recipe
tags and we're looking for a element and
background will be equal to the primary
500
so primary hyphen hyphen primary 500
then as far as the border radius or not
blue or bottom sorry border radius
that's going to be equal to a border
radius css variable
then we want to set up some kind of
color that's going to be equal to white
and then as far as the padding
top
is actually going to be quite small so
0.05 rems and as far as left and right
we're going to go with 0.5 rms
and then we also want to add a little
bit of margin we're not going to go with
top bottom so that's why it's going to
be 0 but left and right is going to be
0.25
rems then we want to go with text
transform and capitalize so text
transform and capitalize and lastly like
i said we want to worry about that to
com layout once we get to the big screen
and since i'm lazy
typing the media queries let me just
select this code
copy and paste
and we just need to change some values
around where the min width still will be
992. so that stays the same point in
here we want to go recipe hyphen
hero and once we get to the big screen i
just want to change it to 2 column
layout and as far as the image is going
to be 4 fractions and when it comes to
the text as well as the icons and all
that it's going to be 5 fractions and
again since i want both of them to be in
the center we're just gonna go with
align items in the center since the
height for one of them probably is gonna
be bigger
and if we go to the big screen notice
now in this case the image is the one
that is smaller on a big screen
therefore it's sitting right in the
center so that's the look that we have
for the hero beautiful congrats we have
finally arrived at the last step
and essentially in here we want to set
up the instructions ingredients and
tools
but before we do that there's actually a
tiny typo here where notice the recipe
info it's not recipe info should be
recipe hero now of course my text is
gray and essentially i'm looking here
for 600. now everything is just like in
the final project
and we'll start in a single recipe
and you know what in this case i'll
collapse the hero
just so it's not in a way and we're
looking for recipe content that's the
one we want to set up and here we'll
have two column layout therefore inside
of the section first i want to set up
that article and then there's going to
be another article and since i was lazy
as far as the class names i just set it
up as
second
column that's it so in here in the
second column this is where we'll place
the ingredients
and the tools but first we'll worry
about the instructions so instructions
of course are going to go in our first
column and i want to start with heading
4 and we'll just say instructions then
we'll set up a single instruction
comment and after that let's go with div
with the same class so single
and instruction
now instead of the div
if you take a look at the complete
project you'll notice this step
and then the horizontal line so that's
going to be in our header and then we'll
have some kind of text so let me start
by getting this text here just because i
want to speed this up so first i'm going
to set up the paragraph but above the
paragraph there's going to be a header
and inside of it we'll have another
paragraph and i'm going to go with step
one
and then right next to it we want to
place a empty div and yes this div needs
to be here now there's million different
ways how we can set it up but in this
case i just went with extra html element
and once i have this single instruction
i just want to copy and paste and let me
take a look i believe i have three
so let me just copy and paste one two
then we want to change the step and this
is going to be two this is going to be
three
and just to stay consistent
i'll also take this text
and add in step number two
and then the same thing for step number
three of course you can keep all of them
the same it doesn't really matter let me
save it okay so i have step one two and
three and then inside of the second
column this is where we wanna set up the
ingredients
and we also wanna go with those now both
of them are gonna be in separate divs so
let's go with div inside of it we're
going to go with heading 4 and
ingredients
hopefully i can spell it correctly
because that's usually an issue
and we're just looking for paragraph
and we'll add a class of single
ingredient
and then as far as the value again yes i
know that it's probably annoying to some
people but we'll just copy and paste
since i don't see the point of setting
up everything from the scratch
and what you want to do is just take
this paragraph so not the heading for
just a paragraph with the same class and
you probably want to copy and paste at
least in my case i'm going to copy and
paste this two times and we just want to
change these values around
so we want to select this one
and we want to do the same thing
for the third one as well
and then the same goes for the tools
but of course the difference is the
class name
as well as the text so we can copy and
paste or we can set up everything from
scratch in this case i think i'm going
to go
with setting up everything from scratch
so div
then heading for
tools
and then let's go with paragraph
and let's add that class here so class
and we're looking for a single tool and
as far as the value again
let's just take these ones copy and
paste once i have the first tool i'm
just going to copy and paste
and essentially get those values once i
have the html
now let's navigate to main css
and let's continue over here first we'll
worry about the recipe content so now of
course i'm talking about the container
where both the instructions
and ingredients and tools are sitting
because we'll have two column layout so
let's go here with recipe
recipe hyphen content
and we're going to be looking for the
padding top bottom three rems and then
left and right zero then we want to go
with display grid so that's of course
our small screen layout and we'll set it
up as gap
two regems four rows and five rem four
columns but of course we only have the
rows on a small screen and then let's go
with a media query and if you want of
course you can add it here as well just
make sure that you move this media query
below the recipe content otherwise
there's going to be a mess up you know
what in my case just stay consistent i'm
just going to copy and paste
and we're looking for recipe content i
want to go with grid template columns
and as far as the values we'll go with
two fractions so that's for the first
column that's four instructions and then
one fraction for the other value so now
if we go to the big screen check it out
we have the instructions as well as
ingredients and tools in the second
column and then slowly but shortly let's
start working on those instructions
so we're looking for
single
instruction
and then first i want to go with header
and this is going to be a display grid
so now of course i'm dealing with this
step
and the horizontal line that we cannot
see yet as far as the setup is going to
be grid template columns we're looking
for auto one fraction
so the step will have its height or i'm
sorry it's width and then the horizontal
line is going to take up the rest i also
want to add a little bit of gap and here
i'm going to go
1.5 rems and since i want that
horizontal line in the center we're
going to go with align items and center
let's save it the reason why we don't
see anything is because we haven't
styled that horizontal line so why don't
we do that first let's go with single
instruction
then we're looking for the header and
then more specifically a div
and here let's go with
height 2 pixels and background will be a
gray one and i think i'm going to go
with that 300. we have our single recipe
that's good and we also have that
horizontal line now there's still some
things we need to add don't worry about
it as long as you can see this
horizontal line that means that we are
moving in the right direction now i'm
going to hop back to the header and more
specifically the paragraph so we're
looking for single
instruction
then we're looking for a header
and instead of the div we're looking for
the paragraph
and in this case i want to go with text
transform and we'll set it up as upper
case so now of course we're dealing with
that step one two and three
then let's go with font weight
and we'll set it up as 600 okay and
let's add right away a margin bottom to
be zero so margin bottom zero and i also
want to change the color and we'll set
it up as primary
once we save everything works and lastly
when it comes to the instruction
so this one over here
i want to set up a different gray tone
and in order to target that since i
don't want to select this paragraph over
here i'm just going to say single
single instruction
then header
and then i'm just targeting the
paragraph and you're not actually need
to remove this error my bad so basically
i'm looking for the entire paragraph
therefore i'll go
single instruction and only the direct
child of that instruction which is a
paragraph will have that color and gray
so go here with color and we're looking
for gray
and i think i'm going to go with 700 now
of course this one is a little bit
lighter if you don't believe me you can
actually set this up as 300 and you'll
clearly see that i'm targeting the
correct paragraph then we want to style
the second column
so let's keep moving we'll say second
column
and in this case there's not much to it
we'll say display grid we're looking for
grid in this case
now i do want to add a row gap and
that's going to be equal to 2 rems so
that's the distance in between and now
let's just target the single ingredient
as well as a single tool now when it
comes to single ingredient so let me
again make sure that i spell this
correctly i'm looking for border bottom
so border bottom and that's going to be
two pixels solid and we're looking for
the gray one so let's set up here var
and then we're looking for gray and then
300 that's going to be the border i also
want to add a little bit of padding in
the bottom padding bottom
0.75 rams and then as far as the color
i'm gonna go with that gray 700
and then the same goes for single tool
so single tool in here
will go with the same border
so copy and paste
and the same goes for padding so pretty
much the same stuff
just the colors are going to be
different where i'm going to go to color
and i'm looking for my primary 500 and
then as far as text i just want to
capitalize so text transform
and we'll set it up as capitalized
and once all of this is in place we're
done with the project
congratulations and i hope to see you
next one